scree form welcomed this back to
woodsborough high school it doesn't look
exactly the same but this could
technically be a different entrance and
this could just be a different part of
the building but one aspect that is
definitely a new addition which you
might have missed is this bus dedicated
to the late principal arthur hembry who
is one of the victims in scream one
here's a little bit of a better look
from a behind the scenes photo for other
references that you might not have
noticed like the movie props featured in
the background of stabithon stick around
to the end of this video this video is
sponsored by nordvpn
welcome to things you missed i am don't
look at my tits i have a mind morris and
if you remember that reference it
probably hasn't been long since you last
watched screeform and i actually think
this is one of the most warranted
examples of putting a number in the
title in place of a letter in a movie
like 7n or
13 ghosts there's no real reason for it
other than style but since this movie
serves as a satire of horror movie
remakes most of which have the same
title as the original inserting the
number 4 allows you to read it as just
scream while it's still differentiating
that this is the fourth movie which
makes it all the more disappointing that
they didn't follow suit with scream 2022
by calling it five cream let's get in to
the things you missed
being a remake this one opens exactly
the same way that the original did with
a teen girl receiving a phone call
sherry and trudy are trying to pick a
movie and we see the blue screen on the
tv something that i talked about when i
covered the original stream which
represents the idea that a movie is
about to begin not only for us the
audience but also the characters who are
somewhat aware that they're living
through a movie however this is the
first movie to take place well after the
others it's set in 2010 so the new
horror reference points for the young
characters are naughty's horror like saw
in final destination saw in particular
seems to have the biggest influence on
scream 4. it's the movie that sherry
chooses for the movie night and the
color grade takes after the saw look for
example look at the first outdoor scene
and how the bloom resembles the look of
the public execution trap from saw7 or
for a better idea of exactly how the
look of this movie differs from the
previous ones try comparing the stab
footage from scream 2 to that of the
fourth movie there are also a few scenes
that seem to have saw's imprint on them
olivia encounters her masked attacker
hiding in her closet just like adam from
saw rebecca is ambushed in an empty
parking garage just like dr gordon from
saw one of the side characters is robbie
mercer who's played by eric nudsen he
was daniel matthews in saw too and both
of them know a lot about cameras stab is
now a seven movie series just like how
saw was at the time stab-a-thon is held
in an abandoned barn this was well
before jigsaw the saw movie that's set
in an abandoned barn but gail's coming
across this creepy pig head next to
these rusty gears looks like something
right out of the original saw saga or as
some of you suggested on my saw videos
the saga the opening of scree form also
serves as a mission statement about what
we should expect for this movie and that
is to expect the unexpected
the unexpected is the new cliche modern
audiences get savvy to the rules of the
originals so the reversals become the
new standard the intro does this with
its false openings first we see two
girls get killed turns out that just
stabs sex then we see some medicine
commentary from our new characters it's
also predictable there's no element of
surprise you can see everything coming
but that just turns out to be stab seven
so we're seeing firsthand how the
filmmakers are now actively trying to do
what the audience doesn't expect in the
decades since stab 3. and this of course
also applies to our movie stream four
street form so after those two false
intros we meet our real intro characters
marnie cooper and jenny randall marnie
does share a last name with cc cooper
from scream 2 but they probably aren't
related despite their shared eye and
hair color i'm actually more interested
in her first name marnie because it
brings to mind the 1964 alfred hitchcock
film being one of the most important
figures in the horror genre hitchcock
has already been the subject of several
homages in the stream franchise like
billy loomish sharing a name with sam
lumus from psycho the shower shot from
psycho being in stab and one of the
actresses in scream 3 incorrectly
identifying it as a reference to vertigo
among others in the classroom or cinema
club is held you can spot a vertigo
poster on the chalkboard there's a
lesson about the prot structure of
hitchcock's rear window and kirby's room
has a rear window poster as well marnie
may not be the only hitchcock namesake
sydney has a publicist named rebecca
which could be an homage to hitchcock's
1940 film rebecca and the police officer
perkins is actually named anthony
perkins we hear his partner call him
that
anthony perkins is the actor who played
norman bates in psycho the rest of the
intro sequence features a lot of fun
homages to the scream franchise like
ghostface trying to tell jenny to think
of him as her director you're in my
movie you got a fun part so don't blow
it the last villain literally was the
director of stab three marnie is sent
crashing through the glass door a la
steve orth from scream but you you're
the dumb blonde with the big tits we'll
have some fun with you before you die
and just like sydney predicted in the
first screen she makes the mistake of
running up the stairs rather than out
the front door she ends up going up to
the attic like sydney did to escape a
ghost face at stu's house and then
eventually to the garage where her
escape is spoiled by the garage door
just like tatum in scream dewey is woken
up by his ringtone
[Music]
the song is axel f from the soundtrack
of beverly hills cop and dewey is also a
cop again he's now the sheriff of
woodsboro also of note this song has
been remade many times by the likes of
technocop clock and yes crazy frog
soon we meet the next generation of
woodsboro high school students it seems
that kirby knows who the killer is
without actually knowing who the killer
is before you get in the car you have to
promise not to kill me there's a similar
foreshadowing moment like this later
when officer haas is doing a crossword
puzzle and asks perkins for a
four-letter word for courage
good it would not be long after that
when olivia's guts would be ripped out
by ghost face this event is also
foreshadowed by the chinese takeout
boxes that have a red splatter design
but before we get there we would check
in on the current state of gail reilly
whose office plays host to a few more
things you missed
as the new sheriff of the town deputy
dewey reilly oversees everything that
happens in woodsboro but can he see why
kids love nordvpn
the speeds are blazing fast want to see
me connect a nordvpn wanna see me do it
again it's easy to use connect with one
click or just set up auto connect so
you're always protected with nordvpn
third parties will not be able to spy on
your online activity even your internet
service provider and your government
will have no idea if you illegally
streamed that new movie or not because
it's none of their business you want
more content let's talk about content
nord's got over 5 400 servers in 60
countries meaning you can change your
virtual location and access way more
movies and shows for example stream 4
isn't available on netflix in my country
but if i just click on this united
kingdom server the brits got the hook up
at just over three dollars per month i
don't know why you wouldn't get nord for
the cost of a beverage you too can have
that peace of mind when browsing the web
by clicking the link in the description
at nordvpn.com
cz's worldvpn but wait when you use my
link you also get one month free and a
30-day money-back guarantee so you have
no reason not to go try it click the
link in the description to get started
each new character in the fourth
installment of scream is a spiritual
successor to one of the characters from
the original stream which is why it's a
satire of horror movie remix like a
remake you have new actors playing old
roles jill is the new sydney prescott a
high school student thrust into danger
due to the attack of her family member
trevor is billy loomis the boyfriend who
becomes a major suspect kirby is randy
meeks the biggest horror film buff of
the friend group and walking knowledge
database olivia is tatum riley the
attractive and popular girl who dies way
too early charlie is stu macher the
easily peer pressured friend robbie
mercer is kenny the camera guy and
rebecca is gayle weather's the media she
even makes the comparison between dewey
and barney fife just like gail did back
in stream two
page 32
deputy dewey filled the room with this
barney fife-ish presence thank you miss
wait barney fife i'm running an event
here speaking of gail she's now writing
a work of fiction after penning the book
trilogy that became the basis for the
stab movies and we can see them right
here the woodsboro murders college
terror and hollywood horror it seems
that she also wrote other stories about
a ghost face killer because there's this
additional book ghostface returns which
we get a better look at later in jill's
room this is probably the basis for the
fictional stab movies four through seven
after news that the killings have
started again breaks we see the
woodsboro police station and if you
pause you can see the kqis6 van working
by in the foreground this is the same
station that gail worked for back in
scream one where the van was parked
outside during stumacker's party we also
see the channel 6 microphone appear a
couple of times throughout the movie
rebecca is celebrating the news of the
two girls being butchered and she calls
it a payday the media sensationalizing
the crimes has been a theme that has run
through each of the screen movies so far
in the first and second films it's the
tv news media in the third it's the
hollywood film industry and now we're
seeing it happen in publishing there
would also be another angle present to
this in screen four social media robbie
gets involved as essentially what we
would now call the irl streamer and the
killers are recording all of their kills
which jill plans to use to help frame
trevor and charlie and anticipates that
the footage will go viral and garner her
more attention however she fails so this
part never pans out later in the movie
rebecca tries to convince sydney to sign
a new book deal you're a victim for life
so embrace it and this is another aspect
of the social commentary about the media
rebecca doesn't understand the point of
sydney's book it's about her journey to
no longer be the victim jill on the
other hand is on a journey to become the
victim how do you think people become
famous anymore
you don't have to achieve anything
you just gotta have [ __ ] up [ __ ]
happen to you she's an extreme example
of someone with what we would now call a
victim mentality like the original
stream social commentary about
sensationalizing violence in the news
and scream 3's commentary about
inappropriate relations in hollywood
spreeform's take on victim mentality has
only become more relevant over the years
as more and more people try to invent a
scenario where they're perceived as
having been wronged with the intention
of going viral the my experience with
blank trope on social media has become
as cliche as the slasher movies that
randy idolized in scream he had me
unfollow all of them which to me was
really weird and i didn't like it but
anyway when rebecca meets gail gail
tells her that she has gail reilly now
she's been married to dewey for 10 years
to which rebecca is surprised it always
seemed like more of a movie romance than
a real one because it was a movie and in
real life youtube never be
in my scream 3 video i mentioned that
dewey and gail's marriage was one of the
many plot elements inspired by real life
because david arquette and courtney cox
actually got married now they had
actually been married for 10 years and
like in the movie their relationship was
in trouble they separated in real life
in 2010 the same year that this movie is
set the trouble in their on-screen
marriage is exemplified that evening at
the house in a line that also serves as
another callback to that dewey and gel
seen from scream 2. this time instead of
dewey quoting a specific page from
gail's book he's quoting sydney's book
in regards to his marriage
just when you think things can't get any
worse
sometimes they don't sometimes they get
better
out of darkness by sydney prescott page
220. later in the evening after
ghostface comes for olivia sydney tries
to get into the morris household to save
her and she does so by throwing a potted
plant through the window sydney has
always been seen as the slasher
successor to laurie strode from
halloween with her story even running
parallel to lori's in scream one and now
we've got her throwing a potted plant at
a house like lori and halloween as
always the movie is packed with
halloween references when sydney makes a
guest appearance at the cinema club
robbie hypes up her presents by
comparing her to the actresses that
starred in halloween and the exorcist
beyond jamie lee curtis forget linda
blair i mean this is the ultimate which
is also kind of its own joke because
they both appear in stream one the
cinema club holds their party stabithon
at an abandoned farmhouse much like the
party in halloween five but if you look
closer there's a for sale sign outside
the farm that says robert's realty
roberts refers to sydney's mom's side of
the family her mother was maureen
roberts before getting married and the
sydney's aunt is kate roberts she is the
realtor that this sign is referring to
earlier drafts of the script make
mention of her profession kate takes
sydney in while she's back in woodsboro
we can assume that sydney's dad moved
away or died because he's not in the
movie so sydney is staying with a
realtor who happens to be selling the
location of stabithon and this is
another similarity she has to laurie
strode who after losing her parents is
taken in by the strode family and her
new adopted father is a realtor who is
selling a house the meyer's house which
was the location of a more literal
savathon with sydney being part of the
older generation now she takes
responsibility for the kid's safety
towards the end she instructs jill to
hide under her bed and then makes it
look as if she's helped her escape off
the balcony this is very similar to
lori's strategy in halloween of course
there's one line where sid is made out
to look less like laurie and more like
her brother you just won't die will you
who are you michael myers the last
halloween reference i want to bring up
is this poster seen in the classroom
where cinema club is held if you've seen
rob zombie's halloween 2 you know that
it is not a remake of halloween too rob
zombie's halloween one is a remake of
the original halloween however rob
zombie's halloween too goes off in its
own
strange direction i'm guessing this was
likely a hint about what the plans were
for the scream franchise in january 2010
screenwriter kevin williamson who had
returned after an absence in scream 3
stated that he was contracted to make
scream 4 and scream 5. however the
fourth movie underperformed at the box
office director wes craven got brain
cancer and the fifth installment had to
be put on the shelf save that one for a
rainy decade but as long as we're
talking about the meta of screeform i've
got to mention what is perhaps the most
meta thing in the whole franchise
[Music]
remember that cop character anthony
perkins well not only is he named after
a psycho actor but he also appeared in
scary movie three scary movie is a
parody of scream and scream as a satire
of the horror genre if you've kept up
with my scream things you missed series
you already know that the first scream
contained many references to slasher
movies including wes craven's own work
so scream 4 focuses on movies that were
remade the new version of the video
store scene is the cinema club scene
where we see a whole bunch of movie
posters like this one the hills have
eyes this checks both boxes it was
directed by wes craven and it received a
remake in 2006. if you're really paying
attention you'll also notice the poster
for the people under the stairs a 1991
wes craven production before his death
craven planned to remake this but never
quite got around to it there's also a
poster for george romero's dawn of death
it was remade in 2004 the thing is a
remake of the thing from another world
from 1951. you may notice the poster on
the left is not a horror movie it's a
film called zack and miri make a porno
this is actually a continuation of a
series of easter eggs between wes craven
and kevin smith i talked about this in
greater detail in my scream 3 episode
but the two directors have been
exchanging cameos and easter eggs in
their movies since the original screen
if you look around the classroom you'll
also see that the cinema club are big
fans of the stab franchise you can see
the stab poster right here and the stab
3 poster in the back corner an
interesting note here is the tagline for
stab 3 is hollywood horror which means
this is not the same movie we saw being
shot in scream 3 whose tagline was
return to woodsboro it seems that since
all of the cast was killed the studio
decided to make stab 3 about that rather
than trying to recast for return to
woodsboro little did they know the story
would return to woodsboro all on its own
behind the shelf is the stab 5 poster
and the stab 6 poster but that's really
only just the beginning of the display
of their stab fandom we see much more
that night at the stabathon where there
are a lot of background details that you
may have missed here's a girl dressed as
casey becker posing with a decoration of
the gutted casey becker which you can
see more of behind the crowd right here
another display shows tatum riley
hanging out of the garage flap many of
the attendees are wearing costumes of
scream and stab characters something
that is very accurate if you've ever
been to a screening these two guys in
the audience are both dressed as dewey
and one of them even has a mustache hat
there's another casey becker on the left
a lot of the kids have woodsboro high
school letterman jackets like casey's
boyfriend steve orth but then again
those are their actual high school
jackets so i won't count that one but i
will count to this couple dressed as
gail and dewey gail in her green news
dress and dewey in his uniform
this party is all about the stab movies
come on how many can you get how what
can you get i don't know i heard them
say it gail places cameras around the
party much like she did in scream so
that she can watch from her vehicle in
fact one of the cameras is right beneath
the movie screen just as the
surveillance camera in scream was placed
under stu's television now you're
probably wondering are there differences
between the version of stab that we saw
in scream 2 and what we see here in
stream 4. so i cut both films apart and
lined them both up and the answer is yes
there are a lot of differences enough to
make a whole video about it which i plan
on doing but for this video i'm only
going to talk about the ones that are
interesting in scream 4 we see this card
at the beginning a robert rodriguez film
this sort of qualifies as a crew
reference easter egg because robert
rodriguez was brought in to direct the
stab footage for scream 2. after lining
up all of the cut points there's an
interesting synchronization that occurs
which is that gail gets stabbed at the
same time as casey and stab which in
scream 2 occurs at the same time maureen
was stabbed inside of the movie theater
just thought that was kind of cool
before being attacked gail holds her
camera by her waist looking behind her
unintentionally recreating the moment
from scream were the characters in the
news fancy ghostway sneaking up behind
randy
this time it's dewey concerned about gal
behind you this is more than just a
nostalgic callback though it also sets
up a scene later where robbie puts on
his headset backwards we're expecting
ghostface to appear behind him so it's
more of a surprise when the killer ends
up being right in front of him just
another example of this movie's mission
to do the unexpected that also includes
the film's ending we're led to believe
that it'll end at the party just like
the original but this is what the
reboots do they they one up the original
ending the woodsboro murders ended at a
party so in the remake the party's the
false ending new rules however this also
ends up being a false ending the true
ending takes place at the hospital just
as there were two false openings there
were also two false endings this is
something that happens in the halloween
remake the original ends of the doyle
house but the remake continues on and
ends at the meyer's house there are
probably other examples of remakes in
the 2000s doing this though so in this
case we have the quote-unquote remake
continuing on past the original whereas
in the 90s if you wanted to continue on
past the original you had to watch
scream 2 which contains a scene of a
character named cece watching the movie
nosferatu and getting killed shortly
after for this reason i find it fitting
that kirby's room displays a nosferatu
poster but who knows if there is any
actual meaning behind this choice i mean
it's kind of a stretch on my part to
make that connection however i am
convinced that the wardrobe choices were
definitely done for a reason i talked
about how each character in screeform
represents one of the characters from
screen however after the reveal of the
killers all of those roles are
reassigned jill is now billy the
mastermind behind the murder charlie is
still stew the accomplice hoping to vent
his romantic frustrations with a knife
and trevor is now neil prescott the tied
up victim who's going to be framed so
it's no mistake that jill is wearing a
blue plaid shirt just like what billy
wore at the party and trevor is wearing
this exact outfit that neil was captured
in back in 1996. other callbacks include
sydney escaping off the roof charlie
being tied to a chair like steve orth
kirby being quizzed on horror movies
like casey becker and of course this
iconic line hello sydney
surprise sydney surprise sydney i
imagine she's getting tired of hearing
that in my personal opinion scree form
was one of the more satisfying surprises
though which makes all of the clues
about the killer's identities all the
more impressive
upon re-watching the movie i noticed
that while jill and charlie pretend that
they aren't particularly close they do
sit next to each other in class and jill
is the only one to not take out her
phone when everyone's getting alerts
about jenny and marnie though i'm not
sure why she doesn't just at least
pretend to be interested on a somewhat
related note fellow zack and fellow
horror creator zack cherry pointed out
in his video that sydney doesn't appear
to have a cell phone in the movie she
receives calls on a jill's cell phone
and the robert's landline and after
arriving at kirby's she borrows jill's
phone to place an outgoing call to dewey
to plea for help this is probably
because sydney is tired of all the prank
calls and doesn't want to give any
future copycat killers a means of
contacting her it's a nice touch mr
cherry also attributes a lot of the
kills to charlie which many were
surprised by but i personally think it
kind of makes sense jill would have
wanted to set it up that way because of
the fact that they're recording all the
kills and the fact that she's secretly
planning to frame charlie as one of the
killers alongside trevor it stands to
reason that the police would probably
study these videos and take note of the
killer's heights and broad shoulders
charlie might also be the most forceful
ghost face we've seen check this out
when i analyzed scream one i mentioned
that the poster in stu's room matched a
poster displayed in the video store and
that this linked his character to the
movie obsessed killer a similar tactic
is used here jill's room is filled with
clues this farewell republic poster and
this uh i don't know reverse griffin are
both posters seen hanging at the cinema
club i will mention the possibility that
there's actually no meaning behind that
they could have just reused the posters
and hoped that nobody would notice
because this war of the worlds poster in
jill's room also shows up in her english
class i can't think of any reason they'd
want to link jill to her english
classroom so it's very possible that the
art department just ran out of posters
and i'm just looking for things that
aren't there but at the very least we
can conclude that jill is more
interested in horror movies and serial
killers than she likes to let on from
her american werewolf in london poster
to her edgar allan poe stir to her gail
weathers books books on psychology and
serial killers and even her fallout boy
poster this particular one is the cover
for their single i don't care whose
chorus matches her mo for the movie i
don't care what you think as long as
it's about me this might be more
happenstance but this is also off their
album folia do which is french for
madness and pairs a term that could
probably be used to describe each pair
of the ghostface killers i love this
album and i'd love to talk more about it
but this is not a music analysis channel
so let's get back to scree form after
olivia is killed charlie comes out of
the dark to attack sydney and jill and
jill receives a cut on her forearm the
same spot that derek got cut and
screamed too no struggle he just cut you
and ran away you're lucky he didn't kill
you yeah it's awfully convenient
say what nothing
it's just a shame he got away so easily
it's just a shame you got there too late
of course derek ended up not being
guilty so dewey would probably want to
avoid making any similar accusations
about jill when sydney speaks to jill
the following night she has what she
thinks is a bonding moment with her
cousin you know when people say i know
how you feel but you know they're just
saying that because they really have no
freaking idea how you feel i know how
you feel i love that line because in
reality sydney has no idea how jill
feels because she doesn't suspect her of
being the killer it's like the sticker
on the door of the cinema club says not
your usual suspects jill claims she can
never handle the attention of being the
surviving victim when in fact that's
exactly what she wants even if her 15
minutes of fame really is only 15
minutes and finally at kirby's after
party trevor shows up unexpectedly and
just walks right in because the door is
unlocked by the way kirby with
everything that's going on right now you
probably shouldn't leave that unlocked
sorry
charlie is not worried about locking the
door because he knows there's no threat
he and jill are both in the room already
stree form would be the final legacy of
director west craven but his creation
would live on without him after yet
another 11 year gap with scream 2022
i'll be covering it next time on things
you missed so make sure to subscribe to
cz's world for new horrors every week
ring the death bell for all
notifications and i'll see you then
assuming we both survive
[Music]